au début de la clé du comité 19 il ya un
gros débat sur savoir ce qu'il fallait
faire un confinement
sachant le coût économique que
confinement engendrerait et ce qui est
assez intéressant c'est de voir comment
les débats ont évolué au fur et à mesure
au début c'était je pense des arguments
veut dire pas très réfléchie des deux
côtés en disant que d'un côté lévis est
beaucoup plus important que l'économie
ce qui n'est pas forcément un argument
sachant que l'économie va impacter les
vie ensuite
moi c'est un peu compliqué et d'autres
côté beaucoup de gens disaient bomba le
confinement va forcément faire mais les
restaurants et du coup il ya clairement
un coût économique majeure qui va être
engendrés à cause du confinement
là encore c'est un argument un peu un
peu rapide ce qui est un salaire
intéressant c'est de voir que au fur à
mesure du débat qui les arguments plus
intéressants qui ont été mises en avant
et petit à petit non pas en particulier
les arguments sont de plus en plus
devenue contractuels qu'est ce que c'est
à dire qu'un argument contractuels ça
veut dire que pour juger si une décision
à est meilleur qu'une décision des bons
ici confinement ou pas de confinement
l'idée de la pensée contrefactuelle ou
de l'argument contractuel c'est de se
poser la question s'ils arrivent
quels sont les futurs probables qu'est
ce qui va arriver et je pense que c'est
important quand vous ajoutez le mot
probable parce que il faut se rappeler
que surtout au début de la pandémie et
aujourd'hui encore il y à hainaut il y
avait énormément d'incertitudes de guy
du coup il faille absolument raisonner
avec l'incertitude
du coup la question de savoir à ce qu'il
fallait faire un confinement ou pas
c'était la question de quels sont les
futurs probables si on fait un
confinement et il faut surtout de façon
intéressante comparer cela à quels sont
les futurs probables si on ne fait pas
de confinement et là on se rend compte
que dans les deux cas il va avoir des
coûts énormes en termes de vies et en
terme
économique et l'argument de ceux qui
pensent que le confinement était
vraiment une bonne décision
ça va être plutôt dans ce cadre que
qu'il y ait eu confinement ou pas il y
aurait de toute façon eu un coût
économique majeur et il aurait peut-être
été comparable au coût économique est
telle qu'il a effectivement eu lieu
puisque la logique que s'il ya une
énorme pandémie les gens iront beaucoup
beaucoup moins au restaurant et dans les
bars mais de l'autre côté il y avait
quand même un argument pour dire que
peut-être qu'avec eux d'autres mesures
on aurait même pu réduire aplatir la
courbe comment vous visez à l'époque
c'est réduire la surcharge hospitalière
en particulier tout en évitant un
désastre économique aussi grand que
celui qui a eu lieu j'ai pas envie de
m'intéresser 3 à ce débat un débat
intéressant et ont pu juger a posteriori
je pense que c'est intéressant c'est de
juger a priori au moment où il fallait
prendre la décision et il ya beaucoup de
réflexion intéressante à faire mais ça
mérite va m'intéresser un peu plus dans
cette vidéo c'est de juger l'importance
de cette 9e raisonnement contractuelle
car malheureusement je pense qu'il est
un peu déficient est bon il nous faut
soit un peu de temps et de calme pour
pouvoir en arriver à arriver à
développer ce genre d'arguments
bref tout ça pour
revenir le sujet de la vidéo
d'aujourd'hui qui est je vous en six ans
nous encourager à avoir davantage sur
reflex à vous demander
lorsqu'il ya une décision à prendre de
toujours raisonner en termes de contrats
factuel c'est-à-dire atur comparer deux
actions où plusieurs ça peut être plus
mais au moins deux actions à apprendre
et surtout à comparer les conséquences
de nos actions et à les comparer je
pense que trop souvent il m'arrive de me
dire ah ça c'est une mauvaise idée mais
j'ai pas suffisamment le réflexe de me
demander
ok c'est une mauvaise idée mais par
rapport à quoi par rapport à quelle
alternative et surtout quel est ce que
vraiment les conséquences de
l'alternative était clairement sont
clairement meilleurs en particulier
encore mieux à ce qu'elles étaient
clairement meilleurs au moment de la
prise de décision
l'ajout en voix et la vidéo que j'ai
fait sur la merveille livre d'annie duke
et on revient aussi pour faire la
publicité pour le nouveau livre d'annie
duke decide qui correspond vraiment à un
livre sur la pensée contrat actuel sera
comment prendre des décisions comment
comparer les conséquences de différentes
actions et je pense que naturellement
lorsqu'on se met beaucoup plus dans cet
état d'esprit on va être amené à
beaucoup plus chercher à parier sur
l'avenir à imaginer les futurs probables
je pense que ça c'est beaucoup plus
facile après de s'habituer à mettre
régulièrement à jour ce tronc croit
puisque devient alors beaucoup plus
conscient sans doute que les opinions
d'un joueur ne sont pas forcément celle
du lendemain surtout si entre-temps il
ya des nouvelles données qui sont tombés
bref c'était une courte vidéo pour vous
encourager à raisonner de façon
contractuelle